hello folks welcome to rational
science pretty cold over here in Germany
uh we got I think like five degrees
below zero and uh yeah it's going to be
a cold night anyways uh we got a great
day today we're going to be doing a
little bit of uh math not the math that
you're thinking of we're going to look
at math in the context of physics does
math have anything at all to do with
physics but before we get there we're
going to do a little bit of Extinction
find out uh about some of the issues and
questions that people made uh regarding
uh subject matter regard uh related to
Extinction such as uh genetic diversity
and things of that nature and I'm going
to answer some questions some comments
that people made regarding the Rope
model that's going to lead us into the
subject matter which is
mathematics does mathematics have
anything at all to do
with science let alone physics okay
let's get started with our extension
segment uh different subjects there that
we cover and here's the first one first
uh there's
a an article that came out saying alien
life in Universe scientist say find it
is only a matter of time and they talk
about these uh planets that they've seen
out there that are in the goldilock
zone and you can see there the picture I
had in my um website where I show that
you know if a planet is too far away
from the Sun or too close it probably
will not have life it's got to be kind
of like just right and these people are
talking about that the fact that it's
got to be in the goldilux zone
um you know it's got to be maybe in the
ecliptic or maybe it's got to have a
magnetic
field um it's got to have an atmosphere
right so there and it's got to be a
certain size if it's too big maybe it's
got too much gravity if it's too little
maybe it's got too little gravity for
life to develop well you have all these
uh different parameters and it's got to
be kind of like just right and so the
issue is that um you know find a planet
like that is uh is like finding a needle
in the hay stack you know and that's one
issue the other issue is um that that's
you can say the space aspect of it how
about the time aspect of it you know
yeah got to get it just right um life
develops it lasts a few million years
and then life
disappears and right now we've been uh
with life on Earth Maybe rounding off
500 million years and that's kind of
like a drop of water in the ocean you
know uh eternity uh the universe has
been around forever and so 500 million
years is nothing and what do I mean by
that I mean that in order to see at
least intelligent life like the level of
humans not only do we have to have all
the Goldilocks conditions but there's an
added feature and that is that they have
to be at the same time as us they have
to be developing now so that when we see
them you know we see them there
obviously there you got the velocity of
light there but what I'm saying it's got
to be within a certain range of time
because when we're gone and that's what
this channel is about we're saying that
we're going to be gone very soon uh you
know we only had what maybe 200 years of
magnetism electricity you know to
develop the technology to be able to
listen in or
see you know um a planet that's got uh
life in it of some kind let alone
intelligent life but it's got to be
within a certain window of time they've
got to be in the same 200 years and what
is 200 years 200 years ain't nothing you
know there's nothing there it's it's
very little time from a universal point
of view okay so it's not only an issue
of space of distance it's also an issue
of
time okay um f says uh ask a question it
says Extinction is the opposite of exist
without location you are extinct
correct no Extinction is not the
opposite of exist okay exist is an
object that has location Extinction has
to do with a species you don't say that
an individual human became extinct we
say he died not that he became extinct I
mean you can use poetry if you want
there but the issue is that Extinction
refers to species and a species not a
thing okay species is a concept talks
about many individuals species are like
talking about Forest a bunch of trees or
children bunch of kids okay so uh
species is not a thing okay and so when
we say a species went extinct or a an
order an entire order or family of
species went extinct what are we saying
we're saying that uh you know um that uh
you you're talking about this
uh species or this group of species is
no longer around does that mean they
don't exist they didn't exist to begin
with because species is a concept we
can't talk in physics about Concepts
existing
okay okay uh so so much for that one I
hope everybody can hear me fine uh let
me know otherwise I'm always worried
about that sometimes you know uh I
something happens with a video or the
sound and I keep
ranting and don't realize it okay so
here's another fell says if all money
disappeared we would just create some
new form of money after all that is what
we have done in the past how did mankind
survive before we had Commerce and
money um well the problem is that today
we depend on money to produce food
that's the issue and uh we didn't need
that in the days that we were hunter
gatherers we didn't need money at all so
uh we didn't need it because money was
not used as a medium of exchange to
obtain food today it is a medium of
exchange if money disappears we can't
say well we're going to create another
money money we're not going to replace
Brown money with green money or vice
versa you know this is not an issue of
changing money and saying oh uh if money
disappears we just create a new one it
won't give us time to create a new one
because by that time the whole planet
goes to a standstill you don't go to
zero in in green money and say okay now
we're going to start with brown money
you know uh money we can create we can
create all kinds of money in fact I
think we've created the last kind of
money which is the the these coin uh
these Bitcoins right the U what do you
call it uh the uh uh virtual coins right
uh those that's probably the last type
of money we we'll ever create which is
an an internet uh money which is more or
less where the checking accounts also
went you know we used to do checks by
paper now the checks are done through
the internet so there's relatively
little uh you know
bills uh going around compared to the
amount of money that is in total
circulation but the point here is once
that money
disappears uh what do we use it for the
only reason we use money is to buy food
there's no other reason uh you know it's
not that we use it to buy you know
houses and cars and all that because
that eventually gets translated again
into food the the person who who gets a
salary the person who runs a company
eventually need to pay for food for one
more day in order to be alive one more
day so
uh all we're doing with all the all
these services and Manufacturing all the
stuff that we create is uh exchange it
for food so we can live one more to
that's it so uh yeah we we need money
because of that because um without money
we can't eat someone produces the food
also because of money and distributes it
because of money without money the world
doesn't run I'm sorry to tell
you okay okay uh F says
uh well along the same line as F says SP
says bill should really stick to physics
his complete ignorance of biology is
leading him to confusion economics has
nothing to do with Biology one of his
most bizarre premises is that humans are
too inbr to survive when there are 8
billion Souls on the planet even if the
GL Global agriculture system collapsed
tomorrow there would still be Lally
billions of humans all over the planet
uh pumping up babies like there's no
tomorrow my this this is so out of it he
doesn't know the first thing about
anything you know sure there could be a
big population crash but humans are
going nowhere unless there's some truly
devastating event for uh practical
purposes destroys the Earth and he goes
in there talking about you know the uh
catastrophes everybody thinks of
catastrophe that's the only thing that
can kill man you know some B older from
the outside an asteroid or a you know a
meteorite or whatever uh hits the Earth
um or um or uh some volcanic activity or
maybe a supernova nearby just blows us
off you know the
uh blows us out of the solar system uh
so all these people are talking about
these things um about catastrophes so
the issue is yeah the global um
population will not what what did he say
how did he say he says uh we'll be
pumping out babies like there's no
tomorrow we're not doing it today we're
not pumping out babies okay this fellow
doesn't you know he he has no idea
whatsoever what's going on out there uh
what we have out there okay is that
we're not making babies anymore okay I
don't know if you noticed but the
population of Earth is dwindling in
other words the growth rate is dingling
we're approaching zero population growth
known as zpg okay we've been doing that
at least since 1963 the last time we had
a uh a decent rate since then you know
our rate has come down to one and we're
going down to zero okay that's the
growth rate and so yeah we're not
pumping out babies and the reason is
very clear we move to the cities we have
high density you cannot have babies in
an apartment you can't have 10 babies in
an apartment okay like we used to in the
Farms so we're not having babies in fact
women don't want to have babies today a
lot of them because they don't want to
go through the animal aspect of it you
know you're putting out something
between her their legs you know they
think that's a kind of animal behavior
and uh I think a lot of the women are
really afraid to have babies because
they realize they're going to be first
they're going to be bloated for N9
months it's like being sick for 9 months
on purpose and then are going to have to
go through the you know pushing yeah and
uh you know these are not the same women
that we had in the old days in the old
days women thought it was just natural
and they would do it and they wanted to
have families that's changed completely
especially with the city uh women and
not to mention the men many of the men
don't want to have babies either because
they don't want the responsibility or
the they see it as an anchor just more
money that comes out of their pocket Etc
you know they enjoy life and they say
hey you're going to enjoy life probably
better without a kid than with one uh
not everybody agrees but there a lot of
people who think that way and so we're
not having
babies uh so that's one issue the other
one is that you know if agriculture
comes down to zero we're all dead we
need agriculture but the problem is that
in the old days uh things would grow and
we would just pick them we were hunter
gatherers right at some point we became
more gathered than Hunters
and we can call that farming we went
into the farming uh era but then we
began trade at some point probably in
the Neolithic we began to trade and say
look I'm going to give you a chair for
your corn and we began to trade first uh
you know the swapping and uh but uh
today we depend on this thing called
money and again we need the money to
create this money to exchange and get
food eventually the the whole issue is
getting food but what's the issue here
the issue is that money is what you give
value to money has no intrinsic value
money is just a paper or a number on a
computer that's all it is and so they're
giving you this thing and you're saying
oh I'm going to take it well why are you
taking it well because you give it value
and as long as we all believe in this
religion called money you know In God We
Trust uh well then uh then we have money
tomorrow we all lose faith in you know
in God in money and suddenly you know
money disappears you have it in your
hand you have the dollar bill or you
have a number in the computer but it's
worthless because nobody will accept it
right and it's like we all suddenly wake
up you know
woke and uh and suddenly we realize that
it has no intrinsic value it was just a
number in a computer it was just a piece
of paper with some ink on it that's all
was or gold Gold's a rock you know you
accept the Rock and say okay I'll accept
that rock okay today we accept it but if
no one accepts your rock again you know
from you to them then you will not
accept it from whoever tries to give it
to you so you got to think in those
terms money is whatever's in your head
there is no such thing as money out
there other than you know the paper the
ink paper or the gold but um money is
really the value you give to that thing
because you know you can resell it you
can sell it to someone else or exchange
it with someone else that's the only
reason we accept
it okay uh another the fell says uh when
you die your soul changes
location your soul changes location
therefore souls are physical objects oh
I see because he thinks that uh Souls
move therefore um you know it has
location it can move therefore it's a
physical object that's his train of
thought right life is movement caused by
the physical interaction between soul
and body and know I hate to tell this
fell but soul is thinking it's
conscience it's mind it's a concept all
those are Concepts in fact it's worse
than con it's a dynamic concept thinking
is a verb okay so no don't confuse it
with a noun which is what you think uh
soul
is um so there we have it object is that
which moves that's what he thinks it is
uh changing location and no um uh what
is it um Soul does not have location the
mind the brain has location not the soul
the soul is created up there some think
it's in the heart but no it's up here in
your brain okay uh objects that which
have shape and soul is not a noun it's a
verb
okay so uh it's and it's brain that does
the
thinking okay so yeah some people still
have these uh remnants of religion of
old oldtime religion you know um
traditional religions and they believe
in all these words that were created by
our ignorant forefathers way back when
thousands of years ago we still believe
a lot of people still have these beliefs
and these uh erroneous way of thinking
they think that you know there are
spirits out there souls and that they go
to heaven they move around and maybe
move move the
curtain okay fell says I disagree with
picking sides because I told them the
other day um you shouldn't pick sides in
all these wars that are going on and uh
that's my recommendation to you you know
my my experience I was I got involved in
a lot of that stuff and what I got out
of it is that never go politics again
don't get involved with politics but th
says yeah you should pick a side you
know if you are a mercenary from PNC
private military corporation which are
the future of war and have been uh like
this since the 80s I don't see why not
if you are skilled at violence and want
to live dangerously that's a good
capitalist venture to make a lot of
money from it talks about this well but
that's not what I was referring to I'm
saying you know uh we're not talking
about a job and and choosing sides
because it's convenient for you I'm
saying don't you choose sides because
you have your heart on the side of for
example Hamas or Israel or because you
have your heart on the side of Ukraine
or Russia that's what I'm talking about
you know uh there's a good way to solve
all the problems in the universe in I'm
sorry on Earth okay all the Wars all the
all the bad news you have out there
there's a very very easy way to solve
them all and that is turn off your TV
and you'll solve all the problems in the
world believe me okay and uh so that's
what I'm referring to not the fact that
you go as a mercenary of course if you
go to mercenary it's not that you chose
a side uh because of your heart you
chose it because of your pocket okay and
that's something else you know it's not
what I was referring to okay another
fellow says I like this one there are no
gay animals whatsoever these are just
cases of mistaken
identity okay animals aren't very smart
and they often uh get confused by all
these shapes they're looking at uh
that's why turtles will try to mate with
shoes well I can tell you uh this
fell simply doesn't doesn't know I mean
he he doesn't realize uh what's out
there you know they've taken um uh sheep
okay male sheep and they figured out
that about 10% of them are homosexual
and the way they figure out that this is
the case is they they have a stall full
of uh
sheep and one of them is a male all the
others are female and remember it's uh
not only shape it's smell okay and so
the M when the females are in heat you
know the males smell hel it and all he
sees is
butts and this guy will go into smell
them and he'll get to the guy and mount
him so uh yeah the and you can see there
the lion he's having fun uh no it's it's
not a mistaken identity they are
homosexual okay and the question is why
and I'm telling you why they they're
homosexual because homosexuality as well
as uh autism that we see today I my
argument is that it's got lots to do
with genetic
diversity and we've lost our genetic
diversity over the centuries because
we've been inbreeding and that leads to
uh some of these problems okay that we
see today more more today than in the
past but uh it happens with animals as
well you know they've been inbreeding
Lions have been inbreeding for a long
time we've been forcing cows and sheep
and all our domesticated animals uh
chickens and so on to
inbreed and you know we we get the best
stud we get the we want the best horse
uh to run at the races Etc so we and not
only with animals we do it with plants
as well you know um grapes we don't grow
them with seed anymore it's been a long
time since I don't think anybody grows
them with seed you take a piece of
another a branch you know another
uh uh is it
uh grape vine or whatever and you take
it and you plant it and and you have now
a new uh a new grape vine you know
so yeah we inbreed all these things and
uh doing what is called as artificial
selection and
that's I don't think that's uh good for
us in the longterm okay but for
fortunately there's going to be no or
unfortunately there's going to be no
longterm we're due for extinction quite
soon and so I guess it doesn't matter
anyways you know okay and final issue
fell says if you abuse animals like hon
did their brains will not develop
normally you can't release them into the
well because the patterns uh in their
brains will be all messed up well the
first thing I want to advise you is not
to say what you said in the first
sentence there uh abuse animals because
that means you're talking about politics
right off the bat not science okay uh it
means you got to gripe against khoun
because he put these mice under you know
very extreme conditions okay so don't
you know you don't you don't have to get
into involved with that part of it now
it says you can't release them into the
wild because patterns in their brains
will be all messed up yeah no kidding
that was his experiment his experiment
was that you know uh something happened
to the mice and the question is how much
of it had to do with with nature how
much with nurture nature very simple uh
you know you had founders effect you
have their great grandparents I guess it
was more than was great great great
grandparents maybe right you know they
they were normal mice uh normal meaning
you know they were borrowed Mice from
some lab okay they already had uh a lot
of uh maybe their genetics was very
similar they should have done a genetic
study before they borrowed mice but once
they put the mice together those were
still normal mice because you know they
were like from the wild they they still
thought about hunting and mating and
doing all these things but all that
disappeared you know with the next few
Generations where we went from eight uh
mice four couples to 2,200 mice all
descended from those same eight mice and
now you're talking about you know not
only environment you know uh nurture
right but you're talking about nature as
well because you know all those mice
have the same DNA same chromosomes or
whatever you know coming from the
original mice and so the question is how
much of that played a a part in the
these animals eventually you know going
nuts and uh yeah they did go bad because
like Calon says you know they stopped
being mice it was so bad that he had to
terminate you know his it was just
disgusting to see that what was
happening there and he just terminated
the experiment before it got to the
extinction phase but he ended up with
you know a fewer mice because you know
the population dropped drastically I
think he ended up like 30 or 40 mice you
know in fact there's a study about the S
St Matthews Island about the deer and
something similar happened there in the
50s and 60s where they left some deer on
St Matthew's Island
and these deer multiplied and they had
nowhere to go because they were on this
island and eventually you know when they
went many years later and they count
there were lots of uh deer all over the
place then they went another maybe 10
years later and they only had like
25 uh deer on the island you can look up
the St Matthew's Island uh issue and
there was only one male he was kind of
weak he was kind of dying also and 24
females I mean you would say that's
Paradise no not true that was the end of
those deer it was the end of the deer
and so look it
up okay so uh let's move on to some of
the questions people made especially
regarding the uh rope model okay they
had some
questions uh some comments
okay okay so let's see what this is all
about let's look at the questions well
it says
um says an electron is bound to an atom
is uh is one of the three primary types
of particles within the atom bound to
the atom bound
how what binds the electron to the atom
why doesn't the atom there you see the
atom planetary atom which is the one we
still that's still in use out there why
doesn't that electron fall to the U to
the nucleus I mean the nucleus is
positive right electron is negative so
you would think that you know when it
falls to the lower energy level what is
it continue all the way to the center of
the atom that's the question for you and
the other issue is uh why doesn't the
electron spontaneously fly away you know
what's binding in you're talking about
bound what's binding in an electron
rides a wave after being separated from
an atom rides a wave
youeh you know like riding a horse
um separated from the atom how do you
separate it I mean what's pulling on it
or or is it the atom is pushing it out I
mean how what's coming in contact with
the electron that's what you got to
explain and you can't use a mathematical
concept saying it's the field or it's
the energy or it's the charge or
whatever no you got to have a physical
object okay there's got to be a physical
object there that is in touch with the
electron either pulling it out of the
atom or pushing it out okay and so
scientists have filmed an electron in
motion uhuh using a new technique that
allow uh researchers to study the tiny
particles movement
directly well the first problem is the
word tiny particle we'll get to that in
a minute but um first let's go with this
one yeah he got this information from uh
you can see there I just Google Googled
the um what is it the um filming of the
electron and those were four of the
articles that came out and they say that
that what you're staring at there that
blue thingy that's the
electron uh that they filmed they said
they filmed the electron so what's wrong
with that why is this absolute poppycock
okay what they did there okay well let
me show you why uh here's the article
from one of those says now it is
possible to see a movie of an electron
the movie shows how an electron rides on
a light wave after just having been
pulled from the atom okay so it's pulled
okay and uh says it rides on a wave so
that's where this fell got that from uh
it says electron filmed for the first
time ever ahuh this is the first time an
electron has ever been filmed and the
results are presented in the latest
issue of physics physical review letters
so here we have uh physics.org right uh
they published a physical review letters
and these people um published this
nonsense that they filmed an electron a
a paper written by these swedes from a
Swedish uh University saying that they
filmed the
electron okay so what's the problem with
this why is this nonsense why is this
poy total absolute poock okay well let's
find out here's um well one uh
University Texas A&M the aies uh the
shape of an electron is never static
statically round like an orange the
reason for this is that an electron is
not a solid little ball which is how
they everybody always uh illustrates it
right electrons are quantum objects and
electron is partly a wave and partly a
particle yeah I guess that's a what they
call a a Quantum particle that means
they have no idea what a what a particle
is or what a what an electron is okay
it's partly half half the time it's a
wave half the time it's a particle I
guess you know who knows what they mean
by all that I mean it's either one or
the other to be more accurate electron
is neither okay that explains it even
better okay but is instead a quantise
fluctuating probability wave
function okay so an electron is a number
okay that's what's going around the atom
a
number okay so that explains that or a
wave function whatever that is uh yeah
it's a it's an number it's an equation
it's a number followed by a unit that's
what that's the way the mathematicians
see the electron they don't see it as a
ball they don't they don't deal with
little balls okay mathematics has no
balls okay an electron looks like a
particle when it interacts with other
objects okay it looks like a particle I
thought you said you couldn't see it or
whatever okay when an electron looks
more like a particle it has no shape
then how does it look what are you
staring at if it doesn't if it has no
shape what are you looking at I like all
these contradictions that they have in
every sentence according to the standard
model OKAY physicists call an electron a
point particle meaning that it interacts
as if it as if as if it is entirely
located at a single point in space and
does not spread out to uh fill a
three-dimensional uh volume so it has no
volume okay it's a point light okay it
means it's has no structure at all in
other words Zero D Zero
Dimensional if you find the concept of a
fixed amount of mass being contained in
the infinitely small volume infinitely
small volume I thought he just said it
has no volume of a single point
illogical then you should yeah but you
have to realize that the electron is not
literally a solid ball rather an
electron has no
shape okay so um what is an electron
electron is nothing so far these these
people have defined absolutely nothing
that's that's what uh zero volume no
shape etc etc Zero D Dimensions you know
all that means you're talking about
absolutely nothing so the electron is
nothing that's how it's defined that's
that's the how it's uh described right
so how can an electron go around or spin
or do anything if it's not a physical
object it's it's not even a thing
according to all these people okay so
they have these contradictions they
never resolve them why because they're
mathematicians they don't care about
structure they don't care about balls
all they care about is units uh numbers
and units that's all they care about and
so until you understand that you're
asking qualitative questions to a person
who only deals with quantities with
amounts and people don't always
understand that so here's from the stack
exchange why can't an electron be
observed we can physic can we physically
see electrons it says according to the
standard model the electron has no
extent a radius of zero okay as such
such a particle could never be observed
as it is not really there but only D
indirectly observed by for example the
effect of its electric field on other
partic
or objects in other words they're
talking about a field which is a concept
which is just a question of values
surrounding Ground Zero okay uh usually
decreasing in strength away from uh
Ground Zero and there's no such thing as
this particle called an electron there
is no such thing as an electron
according to the mathematicians not
according to me they're saying it's not
an object it's not a ball it doesn't
have shape okay and the only way they
detect it is through this thingy they
call a field which is not a thingy
because it's just a bunch of numbers
followed by units and they have all
these numbers they say oh the field did
this and the field did that you know the
field cannot do anything because it's
not a noun not for the purposes of
physics in ordinary speech you can call
it a noun not in science not in physics
okay so no field cannot do this or that
and if uh the field is generated by a
nothingness called an electron which is
a point particle M particle fundamental
particle meaning one that is not made of
smaller parts meaning that it's just a
point meaning it's nothing it's zero D
zero radius Etc zero volume then we are
talking about absolutely nothing that's
what you see mathematicians deal
constantly with absolute nothing the
photon is nothing it's zero uh um Mass
right and no structure electron is no
structure no Dimensions no radius no
diameter no volume no shape Singularity
the black hole Singularity Zero
D uh meaning it crushes all matter out
of out of existence since matter is a
mass is the quantity of matter or
measure a quantity of matter then it has
no Mass you know it's zero d uh no shape
they deal with constantly with nothing
because a mathematician doesn't care
about things about qualitative stuff and
as it will be the subject of today but
keep that in mind okay well here's what
uh Mr Weinberg he's uh died a couple
years ago he's a Nobel Prize winner says
what is an elementary particle I would
have to admit that no one really knows
okay that's very scientific of him okay
so nobody knows what an elementary
particle is okay uh why because because
they never Define these terms so they
say fundamental or elementary particle
one that is not made of smaller parts
meaning it's the the particle that makes
everything else but then that particle
is defined as a point particle Zero
Dimensional and they start talking about
the field and the energy and the charge
and they forget about the structure the
the thing and you can't do physics
without things and they never understood
that that you need to have a thing you
need to Define what a thing is in
physics because without a thing you have
nothing that's what you
have okay uh here's a good old uh Mike
Tyson isn't Mike Tyson no it's a good
old U this other Tyson right uh what's
his name um Neil
Tyson okay so this is what he's got to
say about it here he goes listen
carefully okay uh well don't listen you
got to read because he's just stating it
okay here it
goes
okay so the electron has never been
observed and uh and these people people
talk about you know the fact that they
filmed the electron
moving what have they filmed how can
they what they showed there you know
that little blue dot moving around what
is that what have they filmed and we
can't say that they filmed an electron
why because electron is zero D you can't
film a zero D
nothing you can't film a singularity you
can't film that which has no
shape and people don't understand that
that's what's it just blows me away you
know that uh people have not figured out
something as simple as that that you
need to have a shape something with
structure in front of you if you're
going to film it okay let alone talk
about it because otherwise you're
talking about a
concept okay
um f ask here moving on PA says the two
threads of the electromagnetic rope and
why they get
together okay that's an irrational
question okay and a lot of people
understand this but this F I'm not sure
he will probably doesn't have the you
know the intelligence the great matter
to understand it but why here is a
purpose reason type of question such an
irrational question because you're a
asking a question philosophy and you're
phrasing it as a question of physics
you're you're asking really this what
you're asking you're asking why did God
right do
this like what was his purpose what was
his reason for doing this that's what
you're asking that's not a question of
physics that's a question of philosophy
why someone does something okay so
that's the context and unless you
understand that well you know you're you
know what can I say it says why two
ropes don't display the same behavior as
the two threads when are the ropes
getting saggy and relaxed and the answer
is never you know um the Rope is always
taught as you can see there it's being
uh under constant tension by the atoms
why because every atom in the universe
is essentially pulling on every atom in
the universe you know the and they
probably the whole thing the whole
universe some is probably rotating I'm
sure it's not static you know that
everything maintains its place I think
there's got to be some kind of moot
maybe there's a rotational motion right
for the whole uh shebang and it's a
single thread you know and this thread
makes up every atom in the universe and
the ropes that interconnect them and so
this whole thing you can have to imagine
it as a web of atoms and ropes that uh
bind them and bind when you say binding
you know you got to be careful because
people think that it's
attached it's not really attached
attached it's that the thread turns into
the atom which turns into a rope which
turns into an atom which turns into a
rope and so on down the line you know
from one end of the universe to the
other so it's one thread it's not like
anything is attached okay so that's the
first thing you have to understand and
then yeah the thread is pulled out as
you can see there on the bottom uh when
you have a magnetic field so-called
magnetic field and that is that the
whole line of uh merged electron shells
they release thread and this thread
rolls around the whole um Serpentine as
I call it the all the merged electron
shells and um yeah it swings all these
threads around so the thread does curve
the thread is flexible the Rope is not
the Rope is always under tension okay
and that's just the Assumption we call
it an assumption and people don't know
what an assumption is assumption is a
supposition means you're going to
concede it in order to understand the
theory founded upon it and when you say
well why is it like that well because
God had a headache and he made it like
that that's the answer to that you're
asking a question of purpose and reason
not a question of physics okay so well I
hope you
understood and here's another F says you
also presume matter is made of atoms you
just claim they are connected K by ropes
yeah absolutely it's known as um making
an assumption it's the first step of the
scientific method and there you have the
scientific method okay step one
hypothesis you present the objects you
point to them and name them you know
chair table tree Rock okay point and
name no problem definitions you better
have solid definitions hopefully very
short definition when they're very long
easier to tear apart the more more
things you pitch in there so make all
your definitions very very short the
shortest you can make them okay and then
uh you have what is known as the
assumptions the initial scene or the
first frames of your film you got to you
got to describe the scene for your
audience you got to say look this is my
starting point okay and that's known as
an assumption okay supposition whatever
and that's why uh yeah you it says you
presume matter is made of atoms yeah
it's an assumption you make an
assumption that matter is made out of
atoms and you then you say that it's
connected by ropes yeah exactly that's
the Assumption you know what an
assumption is it means you concede it in
order to understand what the theory
founded upon it and the theory there the
explanation uh that you're going to give
which is a physical interpretation
you're going to talk about the causes
and mechanism okay that's essentially
the scientific method okay because what
people want to
know uh or understand you know how this
universe works how does gravity work how
does magnetism work well if you're going
to explain that qualitatively right then
uh you you're just going to have to give
an assumption of some of your of the
objects that you're going to be using
that you're going to be presenting to
your audience and the definitions you're
going to use the key definitions not
every D not every word that you're going
to be using in your presentation and
then you start talking and explain you
know the theory that's the way it
works okay uh F say for your rope model
to be a real physical model you also
need a phys physical mechanism uhuh and
I guess this guy doesn't know what
physical means he just uses his word
physical like if he knew what he was
talking about you need to answer what
happens to those gazillions of
threads okay I don't know what happened
uh what's supposed to happen to them uh
they swing around when you have a
magnetic field for example so yeah I'm
telling you what happens with them but
it says you've got all kinds of objects
in the universe rotating or moving in
all directions how can the gazillions of
threads not be affected or
severed yeah this guy is thinking about
touch and that's what gets them all
everybody's thinking about see and touch
see touch see touch in this case touch
they say how is it that they don't get
tangled so he just rephrased it in a
different way but he's thinking about
tangling he say you got all these
threads don't they get tangled that's or
ropes or whatever right and uh so we we
start with the main point and the paint
main point that this guy did not get
last time he's not going to get it again
this time for sure an object is that not
that which you can see or touch touch
don't use anything related to touch in
your questions if you use touch it means
you didn't understand the word object
okay the Rope is an object because it
has shape okay so here you have it my
famous rope okay does that have shape to
you okay do you see something there that
has shape okay so it has shape but it
does not have the ability to see to be
seen or touched it doesn't have the
ability to touch okay and so to say what
that how can all these gazillions of
ropes you know be out there and you know
and their crisscrossing Etc you're
thinking about touch that's your
question your question is touch and the
Rope does not have the ability to touch
very simple and it's really not touching
the atom okay let's make sure we
understand that the thread turns into
the atom it's continues there's no break
not like the Rope is connected uh or
bound like a separate object to the atom
the Rope turns into the atom which turns
into a rope which turns into an atom
okay so it's a single thread in the
entire universe for all matter okay so
hopefully that sunk into somebody's
brain okay let's go with the next one
fact the final one here it is well it
says in physics we say the ball crashed
through the window uhhuh okay crash is a
concept yeah how does that differ from
why was Billy sad we have Billy and
Billy is an object well there's the
answer Billy is not the subject the
issue in your first uh you know in in in
in that second uh statement the subject
is sadness okay and sadness is a concept
so that's the subject of your
presentation okay the why refers to
sadness not to Billy okay you're in this
case you're talking about the the
purpose of why the guy is sad Okay the
reason and not cause Okay the why is
about purpose and reason okay the actor
in ball crash through the window is the
object ball it's the ball that's the
object now okay and the why is the cause
mechanism of you know the crash okay so
you're talking about two different
things in one case you're talking about
physics the other one you're talking
about philosophy philosophy is we Define
it here okay uh by the way Stanford
encyclopedia philosophy does not define
the word philosophy so they have no idea
what philosophy is you will not find the
definition in all planet Earth of the
word philosophy no one has any idea what
philosophy is everybody informally
thinks that philosophy is uh just a way
of thinking okay he says oh it's his way
of thinking it's his philosophy but if
that's the case then everybody's a
philosopher we have 8 billion
philosophers on Earth okay and you can't
say that the Greeks you know Aristotle
and Plato were philosophers because you
haven't defined
philosophy and here we Define philosophy
is as you know uh anyone dealing with
reasons and purpose you know
psychologists and history why uh Caesar
went to England Etc you know the wise
the reasons the purposes that's
philosophy so we separate those because
you have science is about explaining and
in physics we explain causes and
mechanisms and in philosophy we explain
reasons and purposes okay that's why we
Define it that way and so yeah once you
have that you can separate all these
issues quite easily this fellow is
saying why is sadness why does that fall
under philosophy well it falls under
there because it's a purpose reason kind
of question whereas why did the window
break is a cause uh mechanism type issue
that's why that's physics but then it's
consistent because what is science
rational explanations divided into
physics philosophy One deals with causes
and mechanisms and the other one with
purposes and
reasons okay let's move on to our
math part of the uh lecture today okay
uh hope I'm still
on wave to me otherwise okay so why is
math not the language of physics which
is the title of the presentation today
okay math is not the language of physics
and first of all let's clarify that math
is a language okay so it's not a science
math is not
science and science is about
explaining what what did I just say
science is rational explanations and
there's only two uh branches main
branches physics and philosophy physics
causes and purposes causes and
mechanisms and philosophy is uh purposes
and reasons okay that's what we
explained so philosophy is a branch of
science and so is
physics and you don't see math in there
anywhere and so does math fall under
physics or under
philosophy well uh does Chinese you know
the language does that fall under
physics or under philosophy well Chinese
is a language it's not a
science and same thing goes to math math
has all these fancy symbols and they
represent
relations so math is not you know it
doesn't fall under physics or philosophy
because
science is about explaining and
Mathematics only describes it does it
has no power to explain and it describes
using these uh symbols that represent
relations okay so math doesn't is not
even a part of science let alone out of
physics which just a branch of science
okay so let's uh let the let's hear it
from the horse's mouth here we have one
fell his name is Matt odow and he uh
works for PBS he's got a show called
SpaceTime and there he tries to uh pedal
the mathematical physics side of what
they call science physics okay and what
it is is just bunch of nonsense okay
here it is okay he says the following
says Quantum Fields have no subjective
qualities and have questionable
physicality in other words there's
nothing physical about Quantum
fields and people don't always
understand that because they think field
is a physical object no it's not okay
here's he's telling you it's got
questionable pH physicality absolutely
not it has no physicality whatsoever
physical means object thing and uh
fields are not things okay field is a
noun only for the purposes of ordinary
speech not of Science and he continues
says uh they seem to be completely
describable by only numbers right uh
because it's describe and it's only
numbers what are numbers uh verbs number
is the verb to count okay so yeah all
they can do is describe and they're
using these numbers to describe them and
their behavior precisely defined by
equations what's an equation again it's
a concept okay it's a it's a relation
that's all it is
okay in a in a sense the quantum world
is made of
math I love that yeah because is quantum
might the quantum world might be made of
math but nothing in physics is made of
math nothing in science is made of math
okay and so let's distinguish math from
science so does that mean the universe
is made of math too okay I hope I'm
still on
uh I'm worried that uh maybe I get cut
off here okay uh it says uh so does that
mean the universe is made of math to uh
um only because what because the quantum
world is made of math and general
relativity is made of math and strength
theory is made of math okay if you
believe the mathematical Universe
hypothesis then yes and so are you so
you're made of math okay I thought you
were made of atoms I thought you were
made of cells molecules you know it
turns out you're made of math that's the
way they look at it why because that's
the only thing that's of interest to a
mathematician they call it physics and
what they're talking about is math so
where did m d get all this stuff from
you know uh and uh we can trace it to
this fellow named uh Mark techmar he
came up with this notion it's a chart
essentially and what is it uh he's
saying uh that just an example here he
says uh you have a culture okay you have
um people out there who um uh socialize
Etc and uh you could say that sociology
okay and where does that come from well
it comes from the mind you know people
thinking okay and so they end up with
this culture but where does the mind
come where is all this thinking or what
is the substrate for it well it's the
brain okay the brain is what um what uh
essentially uh you know causes mind to
happen okay all these um uh fields that
are in there all this magnetic fields
maybe uh uh some chemical reactions
right and what is the brain the brain is
cells and you can say that's
biology uh what are cells well they're
made out of molecules you can say that's
chemistry and what are molecules made of
well they're made of atoms and so we go
down the line and what uh Mark techark
suggests is that eventually you end up
with more and more quantitative math
stuff and you started off with
qualitative uh you know language stuff
you know so you go from more language to
um to this world of math and you end up
with what they hope what their their
Holy Grail which is this Theory of
Everything which is the mathematical
Universe okay so that's why they say
that everything is made out of math
including you okay so that's that's in a
nutshell what these people are thinking
they say that physics is all about math
because we're getting down into this
rabbit hole right where it's ever more
quantitative right but that's because
they took it down there you know it's
it's the mathematicians who took it down
to um to ma that say that science is all
about math physics is all about math
it's them it's not that anybody else I
mean the uh Greeks they thought they
they wanted to answer the question of
you know how does this universe work in
a qualitative way and that was in the
17th century okay when they did the
so-called 17th century Revolution right
okay so here's
um uh this fellow his name is Leo susin
and uh I think sus kind or susin anyways
he's uh from Stanford so-called
physicist actually mathematical
physicist and what does he say well he
says that uh you and I evolved in a
world of three dimensions we can't
visualize more dimens Dimensions I can
visualize three dimensions in my head
but I use x y and
z uh to describe them mathematically now
I go to four dimensions or five
Dimensions I can't visualize them
anymore I can't say now close your eyes
and view in your head five Dimensions
because I can't do it either so we're uh
stuck needing mathematics because
Evolution didn't equip us to be able to
visualize quantum mechanics okay it
didn't equip us to visualize seven
dimensional space times Evolution live
this to us so yeah these people are
talking about uh uh math and they're
trying to visualize something which is
qualitative you know like uh anything
that is three-dimensional and that's
qualitative that has to do with physics
right uh if it's got three dimensions
hopefully it's an object it's a thing
and they don't realize it they they want
to quantify it they want to talk about
numbers
that's the whole issue and so the
question is you know what uh what are
these people talking about are they
talking about math or are they talking
about physics okay so which is it and
here we have another uh Nobel Prize
winner I talked about him a little while
ago and here it is he's uh Steven
Weinberg he died a couple years ago says
I don't think mathematics can ever be
regarded as an explanation in itself for
anything and this has not always been
well
understood and why isn't he
straightforward why is he you know ping
around saying well I don't think it can
be maybe perhaps no it's very
straightforward mathematics cannot
explain anything mathematics is not an
explanatory
language only describes it has no power
at all to explain and people don't
understand that including him okay so
yeah the issue is that uh math does not
explain anything that's why we have no
explanation when they give you an
explanation the mathematicians they give
you a bogus explanation they say well
you know um space is Warped and U time
is Warped and uh big bang happened
creationism they give you all this
nonsense black hole Singularity you know
there's nothing there but it swallows
everything in because it's got infinite
mass and who knows what else and when
you call their Bluff and you say what
you just said is nonsense the guy says
well that's not important anyways
because that's not in our line of
business you know
it's not in our line of work uh we don't
do
that so the question is why did you try
to do it anyways if it's not in your
line of work if you're not an expert in
this stuff why did you attempt to do
this I mean it would have been much
easier just to keep your mouth shut and
say I'm going to do math okay fine do
math but don't tell me that you're going
to climb over the fence and tell me how
physics works you have no authority to
do so okay so here's one thought that
tells us clearly okay he says Don sim a
university professor in Pennsylvania
science doesn't explain science
describes why does he say that well
because math only describes and they
equate physics meaning science right
with math that's the whole issue okay so
yeah if this is your starting point if
you already made up your mind that
physics orence science which they kind
of equate each other right they say uh
is only numbers is only math and yeah
then your conclusion is that uh science
or physics only
describes and here we have a site says
uh encyclopedia britanica says during
the 16th and 17th century scientific
thought underwent a revolution a new
view of nature emerged replacing the
Greek View that had dominated science
for almost 2,000
years
okay um yeah so what they're talking
about really is the um um uh the Greeks
okay and this lasted for all this time
okay and uh 2,000 years at least you
would you would say and what happened um
give me a second
here
uh um so this lasted 2,000 years why
because uh everybody just followed the
Greeks whatever the Greeks uh thought uh
was right meaning Aristotle people just
memorized that and just repeated it okay
and so what happened what happened was
that in the 17th century Saints changed
science became an autonomous discipline
distinct from both philosophy and
technology and it came to be regarded as
having utilitarian goals okay by the end
of this period it may not be too much to
say that science had replaced
Christianity as the focal point of
European civilization out of the ferment
of the Renaissance and Reformation there
arose a new view of science bringing
about the following Transformations the
re-education of common sense in favor of
abstract reasoning uhuh well uh yeah I
think they lost common sense and they
just um went into abstract reasoning
especially when they got into the 20th
century and started doing quantum
mechanics and general relativity
it was abstract reasoning but they
forget to say that it's uh irrational
abstract reasoning the substitution of a
quantitative for a qualitative view of
nature exactly you know they replaced uh
explanations with descriptions with
mathematical descriptions the view of
nature as a machine rather than as an
organism the development of an
experimental method that sought definite
answers to certain limited questions
couched in the framework work of
specific theories the acceptance of new
criteria for explanation not really
because they haven't had any explanation
whatsoever or you could say the new
criteria was irrational explanations and
they accepted those stressing the how
rather than the why the how meaning
description rather than the why meaning
explanation that's what happened math
can only describe that had characterized
the
Aristotelian uh search for final causes
okay so that's what happened in the 17th
century uh part of
[Music]
oh oh my
god there I go I'm
back okay so what was it the issue was
that um they went into mathematics
descriptions why because they started
doing experiments and they said look
what uh Plato and Aristotle were doing
you know that's not good enough for us
what we are doing now is doing
experiments and through experiments
we're going to get some objective data
what was the objective data the
objective data was measurement they
would measure something weigh it or
whatever or distance or time and once
they got that measurement right they
turned it into some kind of equation
into numbers that's how we went so it
was experiment math experiment math
experiment math that's what happened
starting in the 17th century and they
forgot all about the purpose of physics
to begin with which was defined by the
way by Aristotle okay purpose of physics
what is it to explain how this universe
works they forgot all about that they
say we we've uh who was it fean Richard
feeman he said you know we we've
abandoned all that stuff we don't
explain anymore all we do is math and
descriptions because that's objective
they say whereas explanations you know
that's opinion and so we gave it to the
philosopher opers that's what happened
here okay that was the revolution that
really happened and unless you're in
tune with that you don't really know
what's going on in the world today okay
here we have um uh good old to there and
he defines each one of these this is out
of the uh Wikipedia mathematics is an
area of knowledge that includes the
topics of numbers formulas and related
structures structures I like the fact
that they use the word structure it's so
misleading because uh suggest that
they're talking about object objects
when they are not shapes and the spaces
in which they are contained now the math
doesn't deal with shape at all okay and
quantities and their changes yeah
quantities and changes yeah there is no
General consensus among the
mathematicians about a common definition
for their academic discipline yeah it's
not an academic discipline maybe that's
why the mathematicians Are all uh you
know in disagreement it's a language
it's just the language not has nothing
to do with a discipline meaning science
what is physics the natural science of
matter involving the study of matter
okay yeah we don't study in physics in
science uh what we do is explain not
study anybody can study without
explaining anything okay and its
fundamental constituents its motion and
behavior through space and time and the
related entities of what energy and
force so what are they talking about
they're talking about uh
space meaning they think of space as a
3D uh what they really mean is they're
going to put a set of coordinates
meaning not coordinates or Dimensions
they're talking about number lines so
space they think of number lines time
another number line what's energy a
concept Dynamic mathematical concept
what's Force
Dynamic uh mathematical concept so no
physics doesn't deal with any of these
uh deals with space only because it's
the background to objects otherwise it
doesn't deal with time energy or Force
these are Concepts mathematical Concepts
and physics doesn't deal with that at
all mathematical physics what is that
then you know we got math and we got
physics now we put them together we get
this mathematical physics refers to the
development of mathematical methods for
application to problems in physics
problems meaning equations meaning
numbers meaning units that's what
they're talking about they're talking
about doing uh you know
uh um solving problems mathematical
problems that's what they're talking
about they're not talking about physics
they're talking about describing
describing mathematically and solving
problems What are problems relations so
you're trying to solve from a numerical
point of view quantitative point of view
you know something about these relations
that's all it
is okay so um we call this you know us
here at this place this uh Channel we
call it the mathematical method why
because uh this is what we've inherited
from the 17th century and what is it
it's a method of research and persuasion
they're talking about convincing you
persuading you to believe something that
is true they say we're going to prove
things to you meaning we're going to try
to twist your arm until you convert and
we recruit you to congregation that's
what it's all about so they start with
observation well observation to observe
what is that you know they just said a
minute ago I said uh you can't observe
the electron I didn't say it uh other
people said it that you can't observe an
electron why because it's zero de
dimensional defined as such it's an
elementary uh fundamental particle
there's nothing there Zero D zero radius
no shape what are you talking about
you're talking about nothing that's what
you're talking about so how can you
observe nothing what do you mean by
observe you know and besides even even
if that were the case in science we do
not observe we do not Gog you know
that's the issue explain tentatively you
know which they never do because the
explanation is always bogus okay where
they what they really talking about they
call it a hypothesis it's not
explanation is a theory okay predict we
don't do prediction no no astrolog
no Palm readers in science uh so I don't
know what this predict is about
obviously they're talking about math
they say you know if the lion is running
at uh I don't know 40 miles per hour
it's going to catch the deer why because
in uh so many seconds it's going to be
at such and such place if it runs in the
straight line so they can
predict things and they say I can
predict if the Lion's going to catch him
that's that's what they're talking about
what's that got to do with
science uh experiment they do a lot of
experiments and they get equations out
of that measurement and equation right
they describe mathematically again uh
equation invent technology to confirm
the theory because they think that
technology is proof of the theory they
say GPS confirms general relativity and
computers prove quantum mechanics what's
that technology confirming physics or
their equations or you know their
theories right that's that's the way
they look at it um they convince other
mathematicians you know other colleagues
right uh called proof truth fact
knowledge those are the words they use
they verify the measurement you know
what is called falsification someone
else verifies your measurement if they
verify it you win a prize maybe the
Noble Prize and you walk the celebrity
circuit now you have authority to trash
anyone on Earth because you have this
gold medal in in your hand right so
that's called uh science according to
these people okay
fine um and so how do we compare it
against RS this is a rational scientific
method we call it the rational science
it's really the scientific method that
we should have always had okay we had
start with a hypothesis okay and uh we
have the objects definitions the initial
scene okay and then we have the theory
the mechanisms and causes that are
founded upon that okay so that's uh more
or less how this works
okay and I hope I'm still on
okay give me a second here and let's
remove this okay so you can see the
difference between the mathematical
method and the scientific
method okay so where does this take us
well uh
one we're just going to give an example
here today uh we have gravity right
everybody knows about gravity I think
and we probably known gravity for as
long as uh we've been around you know
here's here's the only experiment you
ever need to do in in uh in science in
physics right for Gravity you let go of
the pencil and it falls to the floor
always falls downwards never upwards it
always falls to the floor never to the
seiling always to the ground never to
the
sky okay so we there we have it now we
have to explain it okay do we need a
number to explain that do we need to
know how fast it
went absolutely not it's a qualitative
question and then the question is is is
that a question of physics is that a
question of
Science and a lot of people out there
especially the mathematicians will say
no that's not that's not what we do we
do equations we do measurements you know
we do units numbers that's what we
do but it turns out that people ask
these questions you know you go to quora
right which is a question and answer
site and people ask these questions say
you know how does gravity work how does
magnetism work what is electricity Etc
who are the people who answer these
questions well a lot of them are most of
them are physicist or they sign as
physicists and know or their students of
physics or phds or getting their you
know their graduating physics they're
all into physics well so it appears that
this question belongs to physics because
so many physicists attempt to answer it
and yet the phys when you when you you
know Corner these guys and put them
against the wall and say called The
Bluff and say Hey you know you're you're
saying that you uh are physicist okay
answer the question what is gravity and
they say well it's warp space or warp
Time Warp time that sounds like nonsense
yeah it is but we don't care because
it's not in our line of business the
philosophers do that because that's
opinion so why did these people attempt
to do that if it's not in their job
description that's the question okay so
we got a problem here because these
people are answering the question
they're they're giving you their uh
peace of mind are saying I can tell you
what gravity is oh what is it well it's
uh warp time and you say that's
irrational yeah we know and we don't
care because it's not in our line of
business so we go around in circles with
these people if they have nothing to do
with physical interpretations why did
they even attempt to give a physical
interpretation to a question of physics
if they're going to do math stay in the
realm of math don't jump the fence into
physics that's the issue today really
okay so here we have uh what is gravity
this is how uh general relativity or
mathematical physics and general answers
says it's uh warp time you know those
lines that you see there white lines all
those lines those are coordinates what
they call coordinates those are really
number lines and they have these number
lines which is a mathematical concept as
you can see they're warped because
there's a depression there caused by the
Earth and the moon has no other choice
but to roll around the Earth because
this has this wall of time of Curt time
that does not allow it to leave the
solar system that's the explanation and
again when you tell them this to say hey
that's an irrational explanation they
say well you know we don't care about
that because that's not you know our job
in our job description it's not you know
our line of work so why did they attempt
it why did they do that why do they give
you a bogus explanation and tell you
that yeah they don't understand it
either and not does it doesn't matter
anyways because it's not part of physics
because physics is just math that's
that's that's a whole argument
there okay and so they even throw in and
laugh at you they say oh uh you know
they say oh people pay attention to warp
space to the warp canvas so this all it
says a teacher right says understanding
gravity SpaceTime is like a rubber sheet
massive objects distort the sheet and
wait they distorted because they're
pulled down by what and the teacher said
oh my God space time is like this set of
equations for which any analogy must be
an
approximation now it's not an
approximation because approximation has
nothing to do with the question that
we're asking we're saying what is
gravity this guy tells us that it's a
rubber sheet and then they say don't
take the analogy so
literally and no it's uh when they make
fun of you by by putting this cartoon in
there they they say that the student
says oh that's so boring no no it's
called irrational not boring okay so use
the correct word that's irrational what
they're saying when they say it's not in
our line of business then you say why
did you attempt to give me this bogus
explanation for you know for how gravity
works that's that's the bottom
line okay so let's go with an example
here just to put it in the right uh
context what what is the problem here
what's a quantitative problem they say
you know we don't know what gravity is
you'll find this in core also a lot of
the people who answer say we have no
idea what gravity is you know we're
we're still researching someday we'll
figure it
out okay so this is the party line this
is what they tell you this is what they
say fine okay uh let's give an example
here okay here we have good old cmir my
my good old buddy there and he's pulling
on a donkey okay and so we say okay uh
you know you're there with your wife or
your girlfriend okay and you say well
how did this happen Okay and uh how did
the donkey go from A to B okay and so uh
person says uh or your wife or whoever's
next door to you says
well you know uh very simple you know
here we have this uh fellow this farmer
and he's pulling on a Rob and which is
tied to the neck of the donkey and the
donkey is pulled forward you know
straightforward I mean there's just by
watching this you can understand right
in this case right why the um why the
donkey moving from A to B because being
pulled by a rope every everything is
visible there you know the farmer the
donkey the Rope everything so it's so
easy you know there's there's no mystery
here okay um so what's the issue the
issue is um here you have um uh the
general relativity version or
mathematical physics version uh they say
the reason they came together is because
they slide on a bowl because you have
this warp SpaceTime in the vinity right
warp time and so that's why they fall to
towards each other and of course nobody
knows why they fall downwards why don't
they fall upwards in the bowl but you
know that's never answered they say you
know things always come down fine okay
so what's the issue the issue really
with this whole the whole issue here is
the following you know what if we making
a um a uh a change in our scenario
instead of having the farmer with a rope
tied around the donkey's neck and
pulling on it right we're we're going to
have the the the farmer just going like
this because you can't see the Rope the
Rope is invisible or you can't see it
because you're too far or whatever you
don't see the Rope all you see the
farmer going like this and the donkey
coming towards you and here let me
illustrate that here it
is okay you see
that and now the question now you ask
your wife or your girlfriend you say
well
how did that happen how is it that the
dog
is coming towards the
farmer and you say I know I don't know I
have no
idea and and if you compare them you
know the only difference between these
two right here is the other
one is that you can see the Rope
here and you cannot see it here so the
only issue here is that you in one case
you can see the rope and in the other
you cannot and so so the question here
is
um that maybe there is a rope there it's
just a question that you can't see it
for whatever reason maybe you're too far
maybe your eyesight is not good you
don't have 2020 Vision maybe it's uh you
know it's has a color that blends in
with the background you know maybe you
got the sky there in the background blue
sky and you have a blue rope I don't
know and so you you can't see the Rope
and just because you can't see the Rope
suddenly you know it's it's an
unsolvable
problem you know here you can see the
rope and here you cannot see the rope
and the only difference there was you
know seeing you subjectivity not what is
there because what is there there is a
rope there it's just that you cannot see
it objectively what's coming out of the
scene is that there is a rope okay
subjectively you understanding or
visualizing or touching or whatever you
cannot you know see the
Rope okay so the issue is is that and
here we have the same issue with a
pencil you know if I could show you all
the particles that are pushing in or all
the ropes in our case that are pulling
it then you would say that's no big deal
I I understand that that's kids stuff
you know the ropes are pulling why
because every atom of the pencil is tied
to every every atom of the earth so the
closer it gets the wider they go you
understand the
mechanism but only because I made the
ropes visible for you but if you cannot
see the ropes and you cannot touch them
you cannot see the particles that are
pushing if that's your theory right uh
because of that you say well it's I I
don't understand how that's done how
Mother Nature does this magic trick only
because you can't see it and what's the
problem there well the problem there uh
regarding our subject matter today is
that math doesn't deal with object with
things so math is not in the business of
looking for the mediators the physical
mediators that's the whole issue see so
so math you know the mathematicians they
call themselves physicists but they
don't do physics because physics starts
with objects you need to have an object
and these people don't start at objects
they start at new numbers quantities
measurement experiments right
predictions observation and they're not
they're not doing what they're supposed
to do which is look at the objects the
mediators and hopefully you know this
magic trick right the pencil falling
hopefully you know the
pencil uh is being touched by something
it's either touched by something that
pulls it or something that pushes it but
hopefully something is coming in contact
with a pencil because otherwise you're
doing action at a
distance and action at a distance is
black magic it's witchcraft that's what
it's called it's uh the action at a
distance is the scientific term for
witchcraft okay that's what
mathematicians do they do action at a
distance because they don't care about
the physical interpretation and then
they just look at quantities and saying
this this is how fast this thing is
coming this is how much mass it has this
is what the distance was this is how
much time it took they're looking at all
these parameters which they measure and
they try to give you an equation to
describe what's happening but they
cannot explain because they're not in
the business of explaining and they
never will therefore they'll never
figure out what gravity is because
gravity you know if we want to know how
this universe runs we need to look at uh
qualitative stuff and and those are the
questions people ask they want to know
how gravity Works meaning why what
causes it to work the way it does work
and that those are the questions you'll
see in places like quora they're all
answered by physicists the physicist
says this is what it is it's all
irrational they say well we know it's
irrational we don't understand it either
and anyways it's not in our job
description it's not in our line of work
then why in the world did you attempt to
give me a bogus
answer we'll see you next week byebye